myanmar police have hit deposed leader
aung san tsuchi with
another criminal charge she's now
accused of violating the country's covet
19 regulations
adding to an existing indictment which
could allow the junta to hold sushi
indefinitely without trial the move
comes as military leaders reiterate
their promise to hold new elections
amid ongoing protests against the coup
across the country
[Music]
keeping up the pressure despite the
risks
workers in the city of yangon block a
railway line
undeterred by the military's growing
presence
from students and civil servants to
monks
protesters in myanmar know that their
strength
lies in numbers
i want more people to join the protests
we don't want to be seen as weak
we the students have our future we have
to resist so we won't live under a
military dictatorship
even if there's no special reason to
protest we don't want to be seen as
weak
neither do they armored tanks patrol the
streets as demonstrators greet them with
the three-finger
salute that has come to stand for
democracy
as soldiers bolster the police many
civilians fear their assets will be
seized
with access to banks partially
restricted
the military is keeping our money in the
bank by force it's unjust isn't it
they're limiting the withdrawal amount
aren't they creating a riot
people here face steep penalties for
opposing the coup
those who obstruct the military or
police from carrying out their duties
could be imprisoned for up to 20 years
the military insists it intends to hand
back power after holding new elections
though a date for such a vote has not
yet been announced
and we are now joined by the u.n special
envoy on
myanmar christina bogana miss wagner
thank you for joining us here on
dw as we mentioned we're now hearing
that aung san tsuchi is facing a second
charge you had the chance to speak to
the deputy head of the junta in myanmar
on monday
were you able to secure any guarantees
that the military will
refrain from violence and also release
her
well this is the intention to avoid uh
violence as much as possible because i
think they are
very they didn't expect that
so many people are going on the street
and will not give up
and they created a committee of
disobedience and they will not stop
to to protest on the street
we also should not forget that we have
around
21 ethnic armed organizations in the
country
who are against this coup so the
potential of
violence is very high and they should
avoid this
to break up violence because this could
end in a very severe situation
and you have warrants of severe
consequences if there is violence if
there is this crackdown by the military
what does that mean i mean what is the
international community's plan here
well internally in myanmar i would
assess that
the ethnic armed organizations would not
allow this
then also many countries already started
to implement
targeted sanctions other countries will
probably follow
i will have probably also soon to brief
again the security council of the u.n
and the general assembly of the u.n
and i think unity around the world
is very important that we don't accept
this school
you mentioned unity but within the un
human rights council
russia and china already rejected a
resolution condemning this coup
are you concerned that you will not have
unity in the security council that you
might not be able to
bring sanctions forward
well if there are a big players
who are not really vocal on protesting
against this coup
this will also mean that the the
majority of the the
member states are against so myanmar
will
go in a certain isolation if they
continue to do this
therefore it can't be in the interest of
the the myanmar
army to continue and we should see also
that it was the first time since i
took up my monday three years ago that
we had
as a statement from the security council
which was accepted by russia and china
i want to come back to aung san tsuchino
because there's also been some
organizing among parliamentarians in
myanmar
members of her party the nldp have set
up a committee
on facebook we're seeing here the page
here it's called the crph
it says it is a sole legitimate
government of myanmar
and they say that they've reached out to
the un and
other multilateral institutions for
recognition so miss bergen i want to ask
you can you confirm that they've
contacted you
and would you be willing to support and
recognize this group
i'm as as a special envoy who tried to
negotiate
since three years now i'm in contact
with everybody
and also the people in myanmar they know
me because before the koeit pandemic
crisis i visited myanmar
um eight times per year and stayed
always around three weeks so i know
everybody there and clearly i'm stay in
contact with them
that's also the reason i would like to
travel
as quickly as possible back to myanmar
which is possible because i have a one
year visa
and i could travel but clearly i have to
make
also um appropriate conditions for my
visit
we'll have to leave it there the un
special envoy on myanmar christina
bogener
thank you so much for joining us here on
dw thank you